- Good Morning, Believe Nation!
Today's message is Believe in Joy.
Over to you, John Travolta.
(rooster crows)
♫ I wake up every morning.
♫ Espresso keep me going.
- I was always a person
with a lot of confidence
I'd never took very seriously
anyone making less of me.
I think you learn by your failures
and you learn by your mistakes.
But you don't take them to heart
because as soon as you do,
it takes the spirit out of you.
You die a little bit.
Look, the world is dark
as bad as it gets.
You look in the newspaper, it's bad news.
You look over your
shoulder, it's bad news.
You want me to cry, I'll
cry right now for you.
I can find so much sadness in the world,
I can find so much tragedy,
I can find so much heartache
that it will just be massive, okay?
Now, where's the joy?
Where's the spirit?
Where's the fun?
That's the goal to me.
I've never understood why so
much is harped on the negative
because negative is easy.
Dark is easy.
Doing it artfully, yes,
we must all do that.
But, I find it much more interesting
to find out where the joy is.
During those times,
I probably perceived
negative, but I went for life.
I learned how to become a jet pilot,
I traveled the world.
I rubbed elbows with all sorts of people
and I learned what they were about
and it was feeding me.
I had a choice.
I could've believed that
things were finished,
things were over.
That life is bad, that
life's not worth it.
Why don't we all die,
or something like that.
It's not my nature, you see.
My feeling was that
you get through that the best you can
by living life fully and using
the spirit of other people
to feed you, and you feed them.
You rise above it all that way.
- I think this is a
really important message
for entrepreneurs.
I think to be a success
as an entrepreneur,
you have to be optimistic.
You have to choose joy over negativity.
Yes, you can be paranoid and
only the paranoid survive,
but you have to feel like
it's going to work out.
Otherwise you get so
lost down in your hole
that you never come out.
Entrepreneurs are the
ones who make it out.
Being a successful entrepreneur is
one of the hardest things you're
ever going to do in your life.
The failure rates are crazy.
85%, 90% of new businesses will fail.
Yet, here we are trying to do it,
trying to be the ones who beat the odds
and survive and build something amazing.
Where on paper, the odds are against you.
You're trying to do something new
that's never been done before.
You're not educated for it,
you don't have the capital for it,
you don't have the
resources or connections
or family for it.
Here you are trying to do it!
That's what entrepreneurs do.
You have to choose joy.
You have to be optimistic
that it's going to work out.
I think the thing that
entrepreneurs are best at
is recognizing that when
there is some kind of crisis,
when there is something really negative,
it's thinking about how do
I turn this into a positive?
It's the example of when
life hands you lemons,
you make lemonade and you
sell the recipe for it, too.
That's what an entrepreneur does, right?
Life is going to hand you tons of lemons.
Life is going to suck in a lot of ways.
You're going to get blow
after blow after blow
in your business life and
in your personal life.
If all you do is stay in your hole,
you're never going to
create anything amazing.
You have to look at that crisis,
that most people would get lost in,
and say life is terrible
and just complain, right?
Most people just complain
when something bad
happens to them, they just complain
and they blame somebody else.
The entrepreneur grows from it.
Builds from it.
Sees the opportunity in it.
Gets stronger because of it.
They go off and build something amazing.
I think this is ingrained
in a lot of entrepreneurs.
But, if it's not you, then
I would encourage you,
if you're down in the hole right now,
if you've just been
given successive blows.
Ask yourself, where's
the opportunity here?
How can I take what just happened to me,
all of this stuff that really sucks
and turn that into something amazing?
Even just asking that question,
How do I make this amazing?
How do I find the opportunity?
Instead of what you're likely
currently telling yourself,
"Why does this always happen to me?
When is it going to get better?"
Right?
The complaints.
Change your questions
to be more optimistic
and you'll get better answers.
(swoosh)
So the question today is, I'm curious,
when was a time in your life
that you needed the most
to believe in joy?
Tell me a story.
Share it below. Leave it in the comments.
I'm going to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Elita Torres
from leadgrowdevelop.com,
Elita, thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book, Your One Word.
It really, really, really,
really means a lot to me.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you will continue
to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Enspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning.
♫ Espresso keep me going.
Hey guys, there's a special
bonus for this video.
I'm going to include some extra clips
on choosing joy, believing in happiness,
that I hope will also inspire you.
(swoosh)
- As you know, I was a
bouncer for many years.
I remember coming home one
night after a big fight.
I run up to the kitchen.
I get ice.
My hands swollen.
Just another day at work.
I was feeling just bummed about the fact
that I was still doing this
job after all this time.
At that one moment, I was like,
why do people have so much anger?
Why is this my daily life to
suppress everybody's anger
or check everybody's anger that comes into
the giant 3,000 person nightclub?
- Mm Hmm.
- My father, it was so simple,
but my father said, "You know, Vin,
I've traveled around the world.
I've been to India, I've been to Russia,
I've been to China, I've been
all through South America,
and I've realized something."
I said, "What?"
He said, "People by and
large are good people."
Sounded pretty simple
and yet it meant so much.
If you look at my Facebook page
or if you look at the way
that all that positive energy,
I don't think there's a page in the world,
in history, that harbors
as much positive energy
as one would see on this Facebook page.
- It's what you put out, too, right?
- I say that because
if you believe that in your heart,
and not everybody watching
this can say that,
or is ready to say that,
or is comfortable with
themselves enough to say that.
But, if you really believe in your heart,
that people by and large are good people,
it affects the way that
you address the world.
As you see, post in and post out,
I address a world that, in my soul,
I feel is comprised of good people.
(swoosh)
- My message was just find
peace within yourself.
Once you find peace within yourself,
the energy that you get
usually is reflected.
People get that energy off of you.
That's what I've been able to find
from being, you know, on
the negative energy side
as a young artist
to a grown man that projects
positive and peaceful music.
But it still has the
energy of the young spirit.
It's all within the same realm,
but it's just finding yourself
and being able to be within
yourself and have peace.
That way you can project peace.
Especially on the Internet,
you can get pulled into a
whole lot of negative energy.
I've done things where
I've put pictures up,
and read comments, and then
I'll say something back
and I end up arguing with
somebody on the Internet
that I don't even know.
I'm like, you've done pulled
me all the way out of my skin.
It's just the point of
knowing your limitations
as far as where you'll go
and let people take you out
of your frame of who you are.
I'll never allow nobody to
take me out of the mind state
that I'm supposed to be
in, know what I'm sayin'?
Never let 'em see me sweat.
Never let 'em see me deal with adversity
as if I can't deal with it.
(swoosh)
- If you're going to be
successful in creating
the life of your dreams,
you have to believe that you
are capable of making it happen.
You have to believe that
you have the right stuff
and that you're able to pull it off.
Whether you call it self
esteem, self confidence,
or self assurance,
it's a deep seeded belief
that you have what it takes.
The abilities, the inner resources,
the talents and the skills to
create your desired results.
Believing in yourself
is simply an attitude.
Believing in yourself is a choice.
You have to choose to
believe that you can do
anything you set your mind to.
Anything at all.
Because, in fact, you can.
It might help you to know
that the latest brain
research now indicates
with enough positive self talk
and positive visualization,
combined with proper training,
coaching, and practice,
anyone can learn to do almost anything.
I've interviewed thousands
of successful people.
Almost every one of them has told me,
"I was not the most gifted or
the most talented person in my field,
but I chose to believe
that anything was possible.
Because of that, I studied, I practiced,
and I worked harder than the others,
and that's how I got to where I am."
If Reuben Gonzalez, a 20
year old living in hot Texas,
can take up the luge,
which is a winter sport,
and become an Olympic athlete,
if Bill Gates, who was a college dropout,
can become a multi billionaire,
and Stephen J. Cannell,
who was a dyslexic student,
who failed three grades in school,
can become a best selling author
and a television producer,
then you, too, can accomplish anything
if you'll simply believe it's possible.
Make the decision right now
to believe that you create
all of your experiences.
Because you do.
Let's start creating the ones you want
by believing you can.
Sounds a little strange,
but accepting this level of responsibility
is uniquely and inevitably empowering.
It means you can do, change,
and become anything at all.
(swoosh)
- If you have this crazy idea,
you must believe in it
even if no one else does.
When I had the idea to go to
every country in the world,
it felt like this crazy idea.
It was like, this just sounds
totally ridiculous and absurd,
but I couldn't stop thinking about it.
I realized that if I didn't pursue it,
I would always regret it.
That knowledge, that fear of
regret drove me to say yes.
I talked to lots of other people who used
very similar language.
There's a guy from Portland, Maine,
whose crazy idea was
to walk across America.
He wasn't even sure how that worked,
how long does it take, has
anyone done this before.
It was this crazy idea that
wouldn't leave him alone.
So, one morning he left his home in Maine
and he started walking, and
seven and a half months later,
he arrived in San Francisco.
I talked to him throughout
the whole journey.
I talked to him in the beginning,
the middle and the end.
I asked him, "What were
the challenges like?
How did it go?"
He said something that stayed with me
for the rest of my journey.
He said, "You know there were
lots of external challenges.
It was hard on the body to
get used to walking that much.
Lots of things went wrong."
There were some emotional
challenges as well.
He had just had a break up and
he was processing all of this.
He said, "What I realized
about two weeks in,
once I stopped complaining and grumbling
about the whole thing,
I realized that my task was pretty simple.
All I had to do was walk, essentially.
If I did nothing else, if
I got up every morning,
and I made a little bit of progress,
then eventually I would reach the goal.
Eventually I would arrive in San Francisco
and achieve that goal and
reach that destination."
It sounded really simple,
but it stayed with me for the
final two years of my quest.
That's how I felt it was for me, too.
All I had to do was get to 193 countries.
I had my list of countries.
I was making progress.
If I got stuck somewhere,
eventually I would have to
overcome that challenge,
but I could go and do some others first.
I like the logical,
analytical progress of it.
It's something that related to me.
Just keep going.
You have to believe in your
dream even if no one else does.